see I'm 25 do those units our air is
10-3 we have an active shooter at
Central Rio 24 you need to switch to
another area a 19 year old is arrested
and charged with murder after allegedly
opening fire inside a New Mexico movie
theater okay do we have somebody with a
gun
where's he at
where's the guy with the gun on July 2nd
a fight broke out at the Century Rio
movie theater in Albuquerque New Mexico
officials say the argument began over
reserved seats in a screening of
Jennifer Lawrence's newest movie no hard
feelings
um
body camera video from the Albuquerque
Police Department shows First Responders
on the scene searching for the shooter
15.
please put your hands up I was going to
get the police department
separate body camera footage shows a
first responder outside the theater
speaking with 19 year old Enrique
Padilla who had been shot in the stomach
at the time investigators believed he
was a victim but later determined he was
the shooter
show me your ads
do you have a gun
okay stand back here man
okay do we have somebody with a gun
where's he at
where's the guy with the gun the officer
can be heard calling for backup as he
moves closer to Padilla I'm advising
they're not sure where the guy with the
gun is that they were evacuated from the
century of 24. I do have an SMA with a
gunshot wounded
abdomen but I'm not sure where the
shooter is at this time
I know just keep pressure on it for now
all right
stay right here okay boss
put pressure on it okay body camera
shows the officer call for additional
backup and instruct Padilla to keep
pressure on the wound okay
keep pressure on it you guys need a I
have a
um
put pressure on it yeah I haven't put
pressure on it dude
do you have a lead bag
see I'm 25 do those units are here is
10-3 we have an active shooter at
Central Rio 24 you need to switch to
another air
by yourself here there you go
[Music]
so far investigators haven't released
information about who shot Padilla he
was taken to the hospital before being
taken into custody officials say Padilla
shot and killed 52-year-old Michael
tenorio who died on the scene after an
off-duty officer tried to perform CPR
Witnesses told officers prior to the
shooting Padilla and his girlfriend were
arguing loudly with tenorio and his wife
about their seats before the movie they
said tenorio pushed Padilla up against a
wall before shocked right now Padilla is
now charged with homicide shooting at an
occupied building and tampering with
evidence the shooting itself is still
under investigation reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie